trade turner leading it off
bringing a fly ball to center field it's
deep back to the wall and it is gone a
home run slater went to the wall crashed
into the wall and it narrowly went over
the wall a home run for trade turner
straight away center field is 21st of
the year and the dodgers take a
one-to-nothing lead here's the 2-2 pitch
to muncie
got him
there goes bets and he is in with a head
first slide
got the left hand in
high and outside back-to-back walks for
jay jackson jump on top of the steps
right now that might be it for jackson
they've had harleen garcia warming
runner goes throw to second and turner
steals second base a double steal
and this one
to left center and slater had a bit of a
problem with it but he makes the catch
bets will tag and score two-nothing
dodgers and now aj pollock garcia
delivers
fly ball
off center field and deep
one hop high off the wall
in the score is turner pollock delivers
and the dodgers take a three-nothing
lead
and they're gonna get
pollock as he's picked off
and that's gonna end the inning aj
pollock injured himself while he was
going into third
so he will be replaced in left field
and it immediately let lit him up
yeah he started to scream before
longoria tagged him high
27th start for the left-hander and he's
got a little breathing room he's got
some runs he is 14-1 when they've gotten
him three plus so he takes the mound
hasn't thrown a pitch and he's got three
already
swings and misses down on strikes and
it's all in one
and the serenade strikeout
line drive right field base hit
heading over to third
and stopping is brian and here's buster
closing
and it sets up a two out first and third
nine times in 18 played appearances he's
reached base against urias
down the right field line fairball
on the move is longoria he will be held
at third buster posey comes through and
the giants are on the board
belt strikes out
ground ball toward third one handed by
turner
and there's the out strada is gone one
down in the second
the 3-2 de bond
pops it up retreating in the short right
center is trey turner who makes the
catch for the second out of the second
and julio makes quick work of him as
expected justin turner walked in his
first plate appearance dodgers leading
it three to one
runner goes swinging to miss posey's
throw on the money
got him double play
yes he went says home plate umpire tau
tishner
and ruff strikes out for the second time
tonight
slater hooks this one down the left
field line he's got a base hit
and slater is going to stumble on second
and maybe it was a wise thing
lifted down the right side chance for
muncie and he makes the catch oh what a
play by max muncie
[Applause]
up the middle base hit
past the dive of trey turner
another hard hit ball for buster
[Applause]
he hits a drive to right field going
back is mookie gets turned around
recovers to make the catch
and back to first base goes posey
right down the third base line of fair
ball pass to dive up turner
posey for third he'll make it easily a
double for dubai and the giants have the
tying running scoring position
and tommy la stella is going to be the
pinch-hitter
payoff pitch
and it's up in the air
playable
seeger calling off turner
and julio gets out of it
[Applause]
tapper the right side long way to go for
turner backhand flip in time to get him
oh what a terrific play by trey turner
and now he's seen three and three
seeger
takes care of business
turner at third base seeger a sack
flying a ground out tonight the 2-1
outside three-and-one umpires coming in
and say look there was a buck he did not
declare he being cantana if he was going
from the full wind up or if he's going
from a stretch in what manner in which
he was going to do it so a delayed call
and a block
and this inning is going to start out
with a hit batter
to right field
mookie betts takes care of it on the 2-0
pitch
and ruff is out he's over four weighed
back to first
right there he got him looking
we go to the eighth 4-1 dodgers
[Music]
you could use the kruco jigsaw puzzle on
that box way out into triples alley and
wade's going to make the catch
can't believe it and i don't blame him
he just got oracle parked
that got him
slider strike three
and longoria is out one for four now for
him
and posey lines one to right field and
there is murky back if it's in the area
code you know the defense is gonna pick
it up and pick it off
ball to first
easy play for max
seeger will lead it off against the
lefty sammy long
he gets a hanging curveball and he hits
it deep to center field going back brian
it's gone a home run corey seeger free
turner led off the game with a home run
now corey seeger in the top of the ninth
to maybe bookend these home runs
[Applause]
curveball he goes the other way down the
right field line over there is lamont
wade and he makes the catch
bellinger
is going to come home
[Applause]
one two pitch
broken bat roller to the right side
turner handles it uh the muncie and the
dodgers tie the giants for first place
in the division
a 6-1 final score tonight
you